blow their reject nation I'm Greg Alba
no I'm John Humphrey we are going to
watch a couple of Marvel thingies here
New York comic-con going on right now we
got a couple of game trailers out we got
one from Kamala Khan and Amiga and then
Marvel's Ironman VR story trailer had no
idea there kind of an Iron Man VR but
let's kick this off with a Kamala Kahn
trailer talk about that then move on to
the next one
[Music]
James Tiberius Kirk
because for people like me not really
this dress you did
[Music]
don't you
the kid isn't human we did this and she
needs your help
I can't I can't you can't what you're
ditching me hey don't take it personally
kid oh this is what he does
so you're just gonna walk away know that
I've replayed that day in my head a
thousand times no one cares the world
needed someone to blame and he gave them
their skate girl should have some kind
of astounding proof I suggest you both
get off my land
what is that that's great Diaries yeah
these are all from annoying Sudan
you know that was probably the best like
the most naturally absorbed I was in
this story department of the game saw
the whole gameplay trailer the footage
of release of course we saw the initial
trailer a few months back but this one
like watching that scene play out I felt
that I was like that's a ps4 good
storytelling game right there you know
boy sack yeah
density yeah some real emotional depth
to that and I was kind of taken aback by
that because I've been hoping to feel
that and honestly that's something that
trailers haven't been giving me I've
been given the benefit out of knowing
who's involved I'm sure the game will be
a great storytelling experience it's
just the traditionally haven't shown us
that and then just showing this one
scene not even the whole thing just
moments from it but really letting it
play out even the moments before that
her interacting with Bruce Banner I just
tuned in and check out kamal a calm but
this is modes giving more of what I
expected I really liked the samba land
this sort of story vibes more than just
yeah the the big New York set yes action
and stuff like that and also to I mean
to see her powers in action it's like
you said it's both cool but also kind of
jarring yeah cuz of the way yeah like
her different limbs stretch and stuff
like that and and enlarged or in begin
as the trailer is titled here uh that's
not a country you know it could be it's
also I had the biggest and big in the
perfect in diggin Hazim is Marvel in
action you know or at least on her
journey to becoming Miss Marvel and
that's like a character that in the
bigger you know Cinematic Universe we
haven't seen yet well we're getting a
show man getting close you know
this perfect timing to include Kamala
Khan in the game that way people will be
like I don't really know her but I've
been pretending like I really know who
she is and then I'm gonna play her
people are you know research this yeah
user in the game and then when they use
their in the game and they realize how
cool she is and what a great character
she is they're gonna get super excited
for the Disney Plus show so this is all
just great marketing I really like this
trailer yeah I was I kind of want to
play I just want her to see like come
all the con do some stuff which I
thought was rewarding but then it also
gave me a lot more in the story
Department
and I also found just as rewarding
rewards all around that was cool she
looks like a really funky kind of
reminds me of the the role that Miles
Morales sort of played and the Spider
Man ps4 game you know what I'm talking
total yeah like she's not the main
character you play as but the younger
adolescent character who you check in
with it every once in a while gonna pick
up the controller play as her butt is an
integral part of the storytelling for
the rest of the Avengers game and
eventually whole morph into kamalakanta
awesome all right well let's watch the
Iron Man be our trailer yeah where our
man goes on inappropriate sites to have
the VR experience service load there are
those yellow dollar bill signs oh yeah
yeah it's like watching your leg how do
you get a row in a fake adult film title
I don't know it's true so family
friendly we're family friend is a
completely different game right yeah
Ghost
I used to wonder how you did it
lived in this empire built on pain and
suffering more than a dozen people are
dead after hummus involving starkid's
why don't you stop selling weapons Toki
I needed to see them
the same voice actor that wandering
[Music]
well they did with the place Friday
you got a feeling we're not alone and
you are
Wow it's all Br
it's grim
she's finally getting it to be the
villain that she deserves to be this is
canon with a man 1 you know the great
thing about the Iron Man VR is that
story is in freaking matter does it know
you just want to hop in and fly around
and use your your pulse yeah like this
is the perfect scenario for a VR
experience like even to be a superhero
you really be a superhero like oh that
is so cool yeah I believe they have like
the wands or whatever for the hand parts
but imagine if they come out with some
kind of control that just straps right
to your hands you know and then you can
do the power blasts and stuff if this
goes well with the Iron Man 1 imagine
what they could do with all the other
superheroes yeah
like Black Widow yeah yeah just be a
first-person game you have to really do
this is OGG wraps her legs are happen
yeah when motion-capture makes its way
into video gaming Black Widow game ban
from Walmart after customers have
destroyed their living rooms going to do
a kick pulling muscles many had rain
also ice imperil eyes from the waist
down it's just too fun too much you too
interacted but you know like doing Thor
Captain America or something like that
or spider-man oh my gosh so every great
I feel like any of the ones who have the
ability to fly it would be the most
special yeah it's the superpower ones or
maybe Hulk because at least you could
have the experience of becoming very
much taller
Iron Man VR that's a great way to and
what a great way to keep Iron Man and
the zeitgeist now we are Iron Man and
now we've got this other voice actor who
I can't place but he sounds so familiar
doing the role that is exciting I was
totally like not even really paying
attention to the story I was thinking I
just talking with a patron recently
about about potentially getting a as I
have a ps4 Pro now so I was thinking of
getting a VR I've played plenty of it
you know but she do V R for the cool
experience of doing a virtual reality oh
yeah striking Vipers and never stood
there done it for any of the
storytelling purposes and this could
kind of give you the best of both worlds
here but either way if the story sucks
you can still enjoy they have a great
time pick up and play
even if it does I don't know if it will
but he wind up on the time where it's
not the best all right guys well between
these two trailers which one's got you
most excited vendors a digging a use
Kamala Khan or getting a suit up as Iron
Man come below you guys can subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
belt it would like to get a patient at a
shots so I'm very special totally Jimbo
teach teach I never told you this but I
would love to have a VR semi Being John
Malkovich experience but going inside
your brain oh your lifestyle if I was
able to VR and then you know take care
of your baby daughter dance
I would smother her with a pillow and
then I would make sweet sweet love to
your hot sexy wife and then confess the
news of what I did to our daughter but I
did it because I thought she was ruining
the passion in our relationship and then
she will love it too
and she will bury the baby herself
seriously I have talked with many
developers to get this game off the
ground and I hope you show your daughter
she can speak now right I hope you show
your dogs that will offend someone